[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo a América y hoy nos acompaña
para hablar de todos estos temas Daniel
hablando Daniela bienvenida Muchas
gracias María Clara Comencemos con una
noticia que ya mencionábamos en el
informativo Y es que chile le está
apostando a producir más litio y con
mayor presencia del Estado Sí señora
pues el litio es un mineral clave para
fabricar baterías como lo estábamos
diciendo el gobierno Busca cambiar a un
modelo en el que el estado tenga una
participación mayoritaria en todos los
nuevos proyectos Aunque Gabriel boric
dijo que no cancelará los contratos
existentes si intentará negociar con las
empresas para que se cambien
voluntariamente a este nuevo modelo
estas conversaciones ni siquiera han
iniciado y ya las acciones de las dos
principales mineras de litio sociedad
química y minera de chile y Albert
cayeron dramáticamente en la bolsa de
Nueva York pero Cuál es la importancia
estratégica de este mineral nos lo
explicó más temprano nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
el presidente chileno Gabriel boriche
anunció una estrategia Nacional del
litio mineral que será clave en un
futuro en una transición energética y
que del que se ha acelerado la demanda
en los últimos años puesto que muchas de
las baterías del futuro estarán hechas
de litio chile es el tercer país del
mundo con mayores reservas de litio
tiene como 9,6 millones por detrás de
los 19,3 de Argentina y los 21 millones
que posee Bolivia sin embargo fue el
segundo mayor productor de este mineral
el año pasado por detrás de Australia
las declaraciones de que el Chile el
estado será el propietario de este litio
y cualquiera que quiera explotarlo sea
de capital chileno o capital extranjero
tendrá que hacerlo en conjunción con el
estado ha generado muchas suspicacias en
el empresariado chileno que esperaba
tener un rol mucho más protagónico en la
explotación de este mineral así Ricardo
mew es el presidente de la confederación
de la producción y comercio afirmó que
ahora cualquiera que quiera realizar
explotación de este mineral tendrá que
en conjunción con el estado que
controlará todo el proceso por su parte
la sociedad de producción fabril que
agrupa 4.000 empresarios criticó el rol
indirecto que va a tener el empresariado
chileno y afirmó que no esperaba esta
señal de desconfianza por parte del
ejecutivo chileno el ministro de
hacienda Mario Marcel salió a calmar las
aguas y explicó que será una asociación
público privada en las que los privados
aportarán conocimiento experiencia y
tecnología Mientras que el estado
chileno aportará financiamiento aunque
no dijo cuánto y también el resguardo de
las condiciones ambientales
cambiamos de tema Daniela porque a
propósito del piloto automático de tesla
siempre ha habido muchas críticas en
supuestos fallos sin embargo la compañía
ha ganado un juicio al respecto pues
Justin su es una residente de Los
Ángeles ella demandó al fabricante de
vehículos eléctricos en 2020 diciendo
que su tesla model s se desvió hacia un
borde de la avenida mientras estaba en
automático y luego se desplegó el airbag
de una manera tan brusca que fracturó su
mandíbula le quitó los dientes le causó
daños a los nervios de su rostro entre
otros según la demanda por eso buscaba
más de 3 millones de dólares como
compensación el tema llegó a juicio en
California como el primero relacionado
con un accidente que involucró al
software de conducción parcialmente
automatizado y hoy un Jurado Estatal
determinó que la función de piloto
automático del fabricante de automóviles
no falló y que todo se debió a un
descuido de la conductora porque el
sistema no es completamente autodirigido
esta Victoria cobra importancia ahora
que tesla está probando su sistema de
conducción de conducción Autónoma total
y esperan lanzarlo este mismo año en
medio de todas esas críticas que ya
decimos lista entonces para manejarlo No
yo no estoy lista para que lo manejen
por millón prefiero manejarlo yo solita
bueno cambiemos de tema porque hay una
desbandada de empresas en el mayor
gremio británico pues grandes firmas
anunciaron que abandonan suspenden su
relación con la confederación de la
industria británica que representa a
unas 190.000 compañías esto después de
que emergieran nuevos casos de presunto
acoso sexual en la organización la
patronal despidió la semana pasada a su
director general Tony Danger tras una
investigación sobre la gestión de
diversas denuncias de acoso entre ellas
la supuesta violación de una empleada
por parte de uno de sus superiores
durante una fiesta en 2019 la policía
del distrito de la City de Londres dice
que tiene más de 12 casos similares en
investigación entre las firmas que se
van o que suspenden relaciones están en
Virgin Miriam mastercard o las
petroleras shell y bp Inclusive la
farmacéutica astrazeneca y varios bancos
y qué cifra tenemos este viernes para
cerrar la semana compraría un avión
creo que no me alcanza el salario
todavía talle que está en sí lo compró
te lo compro al gobierno de México por
92 millones de dólares el avión
presidencial el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador reconoció que lo depreció
ya que lleva cuatro años ofreciéndolo y
en un principio dijo que no lo vendería
por menos de 130 millones de dólares y
por lo terminó vendiendo por mucho menos
de eso y también fue comprado por 220
millones en la presidencia de Enrique
Peña Nieto perdieron casi la mitad la
plata increíble Daniela Gracias por
todas las noticias económicas y a
ustedes los invito a que continúen con
nosotros viendo una semana en el mundo